la séance est ouverte le compte rendu
analytique de la précédente séance
a été dissoulé y a-t-il des observations
monsieur ferdyck
oui monsieur le Président chers
collègues effectivement une demande de
rectification du compte-rendu analytique
officiel donc qui tient lieu de
procès-verbal jusqu'à la parution du
procès-verbalin du compte-rendu intégral
c'est à la page 70 donc la deuxième
colonne en bas à droite il s'agit donc
du sous amendement de Madame ponce que
vous vous appréciez à mettre au voie
donc le compte rendu analytique officiel
vous fait dire qu'il s'agirait du sous
amendement
4765 alors que vous avez prononcé un
autre numéro le 341 semble-t-il en tout
cas un numéro tout à fait différent on
se rappelle que c'est assez ce moment
qui a déclenché le départ de nos groupes
je demande donc COPV le numéro indiqué
soit celui que vous avez réellement
prononcé d'autant que c'est la
difficulté de pouvoir voter en
connaissance de cause qui a entraîné
notamment notre départ
donc le procès-verbal est adopté sous
réserve et de la vérification de
l'observation que Monsieur ferrique
tient de faire
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement nous sommes
retransmis sur Public Sénat et sur notre
site internet chacun sera attentif au
respect respect des uns et des autres et
respect du temps de parole
la parole est au président Patrick Kader
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre
11 mots
en 11 mots vous allez sacrifier 18
millions de Français sur le tel de la
rentabilité financière avec cette simple
phrase tirée de votre projet de loi je
cite le mot 62 est remplacé par le mot
depuis que le Président de la République
a souhaité que soit mise en oeuvre cette
réforme inutile et injuste vous faites
tout pour que le débat démocratique ne
puisse pas se dérouler car vous êtes
minoritaire dans le pays et au Parlement
la nuit dernière votre gouvernement de
droite madame le Premier ministre était
main dans la main avec la droite
sénatoriale de Monsieur Retailleau pour
empêcher que l'on discute correctement
du report de deux ans de l'âge de la
retraite alors que le même jour des
millions de Français étaient dans la rue
pour dire non
votre volontarisme c'est en fait de
l'entêtement votre équilibre financier
c'est en fait un nouvel impôt sur la vie
votre intérêt général c'est en fait la
préservation des privilèges et pourtant
les vrais sujets ne manquent pas
inflation précarité service public
fragilisés la France est au bord de
l'implosion sociale et vous regardez
ailleurs vous mettez en place une
réforme des retraites qui pèse sur le
dos des salariés sans appeler à la
solidarité des plus riches mais là-haut
à l'Élysée on n'écoute pas on n'entend
pas les français et je me fais l'écho de
l'intersyndicale et je répète ces mots
le silence du président de la République
constitue un grave problème démocratique
qui conduit à une situation qui pourrait
devenir explosive alors madame la
Première ministre pouvez-vous demander
au président d'entendre les Français
pouvez-vous lui demander de recevoir
l'Inter syndicale comme elle le demande
pouvez-vous lui demander de retirer
cette réforme
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Patrick Kanner
comme toutes les précédentes la réforme
que nous portons pour les retraites
suscite certaines oppositions qui
s'expriment notamment dans la rue c'est
le droit des syndicats et de nos
concitoyens se doit ce droit bien
évidemment je le respecte et je respecte
les Français et les syndicats qui font
entendre leur position dans le respect
de nos lois hier une journée de
mobilisation s'est tenue avec
sensiblement le même nombre de
manifestants que fin janvier et dans la
plupart des cas sont débordement
alors je veux saluer les forces de
l'ordre mobilisées pour veiller à la
sécurité de cette journée d'action je
veux aussi saluer la responsabilité des
manifestants je regrette bien sûr que
des incidents étaient émaillés certains
cortèges par exemple à Paris ou à
Marseille je condamne les coupures
d'électricité dans certains tribunaux
dans certaines universités dans certains
quartiers et dans certaines permanences
parlementaires le droit de grève ce
n'est pas le droit au blocage ou la
volonté de mettre notre économie à
genoux hier soir l'interfe syndical a
demandé à être reçu le gouvernement est
toujours prêt et ouvert au dialogue
comme il l'a montré ces derniers mois
si les organisations syndicales
souhaitent évoquer certains points
particuliers la porte du ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft reste toujours
ouverte car je le rappelle c'est bien
dans la concertation et le dialogue que
ce texte a été construit c'est après 3
mois de concertation avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
et les groupes parlementaires que nous
avons décidé de décaler progressivement
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 64
ans et non pas 65 ans comme prévu
initialement je rappelle aussi je
rappelle aussi que c'est grâce au
dialogue que nous avons décidé de
revaloriser les plus petites pensions
des retraités actuels et je vous
rappelle encore que c'est grâce au
dialogue que nous avons amélioré le
texte sur la pénibilité mais ces sujets
ne vous semble peut-être pas importants
monsieur sénateur mais je crois que
c'est important la pénibilité les
transitions emploi retraite la prise en
compte des trimestres de travaux
d'utilité collective les fameux tubes
des années 80
ce sont des changements significatifs
nous sommes prêts à d'autres j'ai pas
par exemple eu l'occasion de dire que
j'étais ouverte à une surcote pour
toutes celles qui auront la durée de
cotisation à 63 ans toutes ces questions
sont au cœur du débat au Parlement vous
en discutez actuellement au sein même de
cette émission et je le répète nous
sommes prêts à faire évoluer à améliorer
et enrichir ce texte dans le respect de
ces équilibres mais pour y parvenir nous
devons pouvoir débattre loyalement
ouvertement et franchement et je peine à
comprendre monsieur le Président Kanner
votre ton vous insinuations et vos
attaques comme vous le savez le
gouvernement n'intervient pas dans
l'organisation des débats au Sénat
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
temps de la concertation a eu lieu le
débat au Parlement doit se tenir dans le
respect des uns et des autres sans
blocage avec une volonté de discussion
sincère c'est le fondement de notre
démocratie nous ne pouvons pas et nous
ne devons pas opposer la légitimité de
la rue à celle de nos institutions
depuis quelques jours et jusqu'à la fin
de la semaine la discussion va se
poursuivre au Sénat plus de senteurs de
débats sont prévus au total vous avez
les cartes en main pour agir les cartes
en main pour enrichir le texte les
cartes en main pour donner à tous les
Français le débat démocratique qu'il
réclame je vous remercie merci
[Musique]
monsieur le Président kaner
ministre vous n'étiez pas dans
l'hémicycle cette nuit vous auriez
peut-être eu un discours différent mais
finalement quand j'ai employé le mot
d'entêtement je me suis trompé
c'est de l'aveuglement vis-à-vis de
notre pays et finalement je ne vais pas
vous répliquer madame l'après ministre
je vais parler aux Français les Français
pourront compter sur nous sur notre
détermination pour faire face à cette
mauvaise réforme indigne par rapport à
leurs intérêts et je vous le dis très
simplement ils peuvent compter sur nous
au Sénat pour être leur porte-voix
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Véronique Guillotin pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre la presse a beaucoup
commenté les conclusions du rapport du
chef de la maternité de l'hôpital Necker
sur l'avenir des petites maternités il a
été adopté à une large majorité par
l'Académie de médecine pas plus tard
qu'hier et préconise la fin des
accouchements dans plus d'une centaine
de maternité de niveau 1 qui pratique
moins de 1000 accouchements à l'année ce
rapport pose l'ambition de renforcer la
sécurité des parturientes face aux
difficultés rencontrées par ces
maternités manque de personnels recours
trop fréquents à l'intérim perte
d'attractivité
l'objectif nous le partageons tous et
bien sûr qu'une maternité qui n'est plus
en capacité d'assurer la sécurité des
mamans et des bébés doit suspendre son
activité d'accouchement mais pour autant
pour autant érigé en dogme la question
du nombre de naissances pour justifier
la fermeture du net d'une maternité
serait nié les disparités territoriales
la fermeture d'une salle de naissance
proche d'une zone urbaine n'aura pas les
mêmes conséquences pour les femmes qu'en
zone rurale ou de montagne ou l'accès
aux réseaux routier les moyens de
transport sont bien plus difficile une
étude menée en 2013 en Bourgogne a
montré l'impact négatif de la santé
périnatale sur des temps d'accès
supérieurs à 45 minutes ce rapport elle
mérite de poser le problème et les
réponses ne peuvent être basées sur des
simples calculs mathématiques elles
doivent prendre en compte les
particularités de chaque territoire il
fonctionnement de chaque établissement
pour vous donner un exemple en Lorraine
sur 19 maternités nous en avons 10 de
type 1 et 14 qui pratiquent des moins
2000 accouchements à l'année vous
comprenez donc que ce rapport soulève à
la fois des questions et des inquiétudes
aussi madame la ministre pouvez-vous
nous dire si vous comptez appuyer vous
comptez vous appuyez sur ce rapport pour
un futur plan national de périnatalité
ce rapport est-il une commande ou une
initiative spontanée enfin qu'elle sera
la ligne choisie par le gouvernement
pour assurer un suivi de grossesse et un
accouchement en toute sécurité pour
toutes les femmes de notre pays pour
vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée
en charge de l'organisation territoriale
et des professions de santé madame
Firmin LEGO
merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices monsieur le
sénateur madame la sénatrice Guillotin
tout d'abord je vous prie d'excuser
l'absence du ministre François Brown
vous évoquez le rapport sur la
planification de la périnatalité rendue
par l'Académie de médecine avec mon
collègue François Braun nous avons pris
connaissance des analyses et
propositions de ce rapport je le
rappelle la CAN diminue de médecine est
une structure indépendante il s'agit
d'un avis scientifique qui n'engageant
rien le gouvernement je veux être très
clair la remise de ce rapport ne
signifie aucunement comme certains
s'amusent à le laisser entendre fermer
massivement des maternités ou remettre
du jour en cause du jour au lendemain 30
ans de politique périnatale dans notre
pays la question que pose ce rapport est
importante et renvoie à l'équilibre
nécessaire entre proximité et sécurité
des actes je le redis la sécurité n'est
pas négociable la volonté qui est la
nôtre c'est celle de bâtir ensemble des
solutions qui permettent de garantir une
offre pour tous toutes en assurant la
qualité et la sécurité de la prise en
charge entre un territoire périurbain et
un territoire rural les solutions à
construire seront de fait très
différentes
c'est tout la philosophie de notre
action et l'esprit du CNR avec des
solutions territoire par territoire
co-construite avec l'ensemble des
acteurs j’ajoute que la santé des femmes
est un enjeu essentiel sur lequel nous
allons agir et nous agissons déjà à tous
les niveaux je pense à la formation des
professionnels nous sommes pleinement
engagés dans une réflexion globale avec
l'ensemble des acteurs sur l'évolution
des filières et métiers pour améliorer
les conditions d'exercice mieux
reconnaître leurs compétences et
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers en
la matière le gouvernement agit déjà
c'est tout le sens de la loi du 25
janvier 2023 sur la formation de
sage-femme qui permettra désormais aux
sages-femmes d'obtenir le diplôme d'état
de docteur en maiotique je pense aussi
et il faut le redire aujourd'hui dans le
contexte particulier de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
pour accompagner et protéger la santé de
toutes les femmes au quotidien nous
voulons mieux accompagner les femmes qui
connaissent les preuves d'une fausse
couche à travers le renforcement des
dispositifs d'accompagnement
psychologique et la création de parcours
dédiés vous le savez la détermination
qui est la mienne avec François Brown
amélioré l'accès à la santé de nos
concitoyens sur tout le territoire nous
sommes pleinement mobilisés
oui merci Madame la mini je pense que
votre réponse a été claire et lève au
moins
l'ambiguïté en tout cas les inquiétudes
qui émanaient de ce rapport comme vous
je pense qu'il y a la sécurité sur
lequel nous ne devons pas déroger mais
bien évidemment que toutes les solutions
qui doivent être trouvées pour répondre
en fait aux problématiques des
maternités doivent le faire territoire
par territoire et maternité par
maternité je vous remercie merci la
parole est au président Guillaume
Gontard pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire
oui merci merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre en cette
journée internationale des droits des
femmes nous aurions préféré vous
interroger par la voix de Mélanie Vogel
sur les politiques que vous ne mettez
pas en œuvre en faveur de l'égalité
salariale et en faveur de la légalité
devant le départ à la retraite des
femmes et des hommes mais considérant la
mobilisation tout à fait historique oui
historique de la journée d'hier
considérant l'entrave gravissime au
débat parlementaire intervenu dans la
nuit dernière dans cette hémicycle ma
question sera donc la suivante
allez-vous retirer votre réforme de
retraite inique avant que le blocage
démocratique politique économique et
sociales du pays ne soit complet
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Guillaume Gontard tout d'abord
quand vous évoquez l'organisation
interne des débats au Sénats je voudrais
vous rappeler que je suis attaché à la
séparation des pouvoirs et que le
déroulement des débats et de la
prérogative de chaque assemblée je note
toutefois que les débats avancent vous
avez voté hier la première partie du
texte et vous avez déjà pu débattre
plusieurs heures sur l'article 7 j'ai
donc toute confiance dans le Sénat pour
conduire dans les meilleures conditions
le débat mais monsieur le Président
Gontard comme vous l'avez souligné votre
question intervient le 8 mars journée
internationale du droit des femmes et
donc je voudrais profiter de ce moment
pour vous dire ma mobilisation
personnelle et celle de mon gouvernement
pour l'égalité réelle entre les femmes
et les hommes
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et la grande cause des deux quinquennats
d'Emmanuel Macron je me bats pour
l'égalité et pour les droits des femmes
depuis des années alors j'ai veillé
est-ce que ce projet pour nous retraite
tienne compte au mieux des carrières des
femmes et œuvres à réduire les
inégalités notre projet protège celles
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt en
améliorant le dispositif carrière longue
et en y intégrant les congés parentaux
notre projet protège celles qui ont des
carrières incomplètes en permettant la
validation des trimestres de congés
parentaux où les périodes d'aidant qui
sont souvent des femmes et on ne
modifiant pas l'âge d'annulation de la
décote qui concerne une femme sur 5
notre projet protège celles et ceux qui
ont des revenus modestes tout au long de
leur vie professionnelle ce sont à la
fois les retraités futurs et les
retraités actuels qui bénéficieront
d'une revalorisation de la pension
minimale pour les deux tiers ce sont des
femmes ainsi dans les prochaines années
l'écart de entre les femmes et les
hommes va se réduire d'un tiers comme
depuis le début nous restons attentifs
aux propositions constructives et nous
sommes ouverts à des évolutions du texte
notamment pour réduire les inégalités de
pension entre les femmes et des hommes
cela peut passer par une surcote de
toutes celles qui auront la durée
nécessaire de cotisation à 63 ans vous
aurez l'occasion d'en débattre tout à
l'heure mais la retraite ne peut pas à
elle seule corriger toutes les
inégalités d'une vie professionnelle
c'est pourquoi nous devons également
continuer à nous battre pour l'égalité
tout au long de la vie professionnelle
je vous remercie monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre votre
discours faussement pédagogique encore
plus sur l'égalité aux femmes ne
convaincent personne de quoi que ce soit
si ce n'est de rejoindre les cortèges
des manifestations vous portez la
responsabilité de cette réforme dont
personne ne veut vous portez la
responsabilité du blocage du pays vous
portez la responsabilité d'un choix
constitutionnel le 47,1 qui musait le
Parlement vous portez avec vos alliés de
droite la responsabilité du déni
démocratique à l'oeuvre vous portez
demain la responsabilité de l'arrivée de
l'extrême droite au pouvoir madame la
Premier ministre vous avez déjà trahi
maintes fois les promesses formulées
devant le Parlement en juillet dernier
cessez de mentir aux françaises et aux
Français cessez de dissimuler vos
négociations d'antichambre avec les
lambeaux de la droite cessez de vous
faire dicter votre action politique ou
bien alors remanier le gouvernement
intégrer et l'air à votre coalition
et revenez devant le Parlement nous
présenter avec sincérité le projet de
cas social est de régression sociétale
le projet de droite qui est le vôtre en
attendant nous vous demandons
solennellement au nom de l'immense
majorité du peuple français et de
l'insert syndical de retirer ce projet
inutile car comme la si bien dit le
porte-parole du gouvernement le pays a
d'autres urgences à gérer
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Franck melonville pour le gros plaisir
indépendants République et territoire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre l'interdiction de la vente de
voiture neuve à moteur thermique en 2035
a été validé par le Parlement européen
le 14 février dernier le vote par les
États membres pour l'entériner devait
avoir lieu hier heureusement il a été
reporté cinédier en raison de
l'abstention de l'Allemagne
dorénavant plusieurs pays s'opposent au
toute électrique mettant en avant leur
doute quant à l'incidence sur cette
évolution technique et technologique sur
l'industrie c'est interdiction n'a fait
l'objet d'aucune étude d'impact
préalable les conséquences pourraient
être très lourdes disparition de
centaines de milliers d'emplois en
Europe des industrialisations
historiques au profit de la Chine ou
d'autres pays peu respectueux de
l'environnement perte de capacité
d'innovation notamment en matière de
carburant propre de plus il faut tenir
compte de leur utilisation qui n'est
absolument pas adapté dans nos
territoires ruraux en matière
d'autonomie de batterie de distance à
parcourir et de et de matériel de
recharge
sur un cycle de vie du produit leur
empreinte écologique n'est pas neutre on
ne peut on sait que la production donc
des batteries et leur recyclage soulève
de nombreux problèmes de nombreuses
difficultés et accentue notre dépendance
Renaud par la voie de son président
jodominique Sénart pense qu'en 2050
grâce à la recherche et le développement
le moteur thermique pourrait disposer du
même bilan carbone que l'électrique loin
de moi l'idée d'opposer thermique
électrique mais je venais au moins
rappeler que nous sommes un des leaders
des petits moteurs diesel que nous
disposons encore de grandes capacités
d'évolution et d'innovation ne nous
enfermons donc pas dans le tout
électrique en excluant le thermique mais
plutôt mobisons-nous pour une mobilité
toujours plus propre monsieur le
ministre quelle est la position de la
France sur ce dossier nous devons
protéger notre industrie automobile nos
compétences garantir nos intérêts et se
fermer aucune
piste de développement et d'innovation
la parole pour vous répondre et
communistes de la transition écologique
la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur maisonville
l'Union européenne le 29 juin dernier à
part le biais d'un accord entre État
membre validé cette réglementation ça a
fait l'objet d'un vote le 14 février et
depuis quelques jours pour des raisons
politiques internes à sa collision
l'Allemagne menace de ne pas tenir sa
parole ce serait à la fois un très
mauvais signal pour nos engagements
climatiques et un danger pour notre
industrie si les choses devaient en
rester là
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
des véhicules thermiques c'est à eux
seuls plus que toutes les émissions
agricoles à eux seuls plus que toutes
les émissions industrielles à eux seuls
plus que toutes les émissions qui sont
liées au bâtiment
les biocarburants c'est une impasse on
n'a pas la surface pour compenser les
hydrocarbures et on en aura besoin pour
le maritime et l'aérien et c'est vrai
pour le if Youle pour les carburants de
synthèse qu'on doit utiliser pour les
moteurs qui ne pourront pas été
électrifiés en particulier l'aériennes
maritime si on veut viser la neutralité
carbone 2035 en l'état ça veut pas dire
la fin des moteurs thermiques ça veut
dire la fin de vente des moteurs neufs
avec évidemment pour le diesel pour
l'hybride des véhicules qui continueront
à circuler mais monsieur le sénateur et
je sais que votre intérêt pour
l'industrie de notre pays est réel avec
Clément Bones avec Bruno Le Maire notre
obsession c'est précisément qu'il y a un
cap clair qui soit donné aux industriels
depuis quelques jours Valeo Volkswagen
stelantis Renault insiste sur la
nécessité de pas envoyer de
contresignales au moment où ces
constructeurs et ses équipements qui
investissent des milliards d'euros comme
avec le pôle électricité dans les hauts
de France pour se préparer à être prêt
ne pas le faire ce serait continué à se
faire tailler des croupières par
l'industrie chinoise qui effectivement
fabrique des véhicules électriques avec
des usines à charbon se préparer à ça et
assumer un changement pour faire en
sorte de l'accompagner c'est à la fois
la voix qui est souhaitable pour le
climat pour l'industrie et pour nos
emplois
la parole est à notre collègue
Jacqueline Eustache Brignoud pour le
groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre femme vie liberté en ce 8 mars
comment ne pas penser avec le cœur lourd
à toutes les femmes victimes
d'oppression dans le monde et plus
particulièrement aux iraniennes et aux
Afghans courageusement elle se battent
chaque jour au péril de leur vie pour
dénoncer des régimes qui ni leur
existence qui veulent les rendre
invisibles et qui les empêche d'accéder
à la culture à l'école au savoir et donc
à leur émancipation alors jusqu'à
empoisonner des centaines d'écolières en
Iran leur force et leur courage nous
oblige à l'action à l'image de ce
qu'était l'apartheid raciale en Afrique
du Sud ces femmes sont victimes d'un
véritable apartheid sexuel en 1973 les
Nations Unies adoptaient le texte de la
convention internationale sur
l'élimination et la répression du crime
d'apartheid qui a permis de prendre des
mesures sur le plan international en vue
d'éliminer de réprimer le crime
d'apartheid en ce 50e anniversaire de
cette convention la France sonorerait en
portant une initiative auprès des
Nations Unies et tendance cette
convention à l'aparthèse sexuelle en
proposant d'inclure ce type de
discrimination à l'article 2 définissant
le terme d'apartheid cette proposition
initiée par la Ligue du droit
international des femmes et soutenu par
de nombreux juristes et intellectuels
parmi lesquels sherine et Badi iranienne
prix Nobel de la paix alors la France
pays des droits de l'homme pays des
Lettres persanes aura-t-elle l'ambition
et le courage de porter cette demande
aux Nations Unies en y associant ses
partenaires européens
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame Isabelle Rome ministre délégué
chargé de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes chargés de la diversité de
l'égalité des chances
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice oui bien sûr aujourd'hui nous
pensons à toutes ces femmes qui sont
opprimées un peu partout dans le monde
en cette journée internationale des
droits des femmes la France est l'un des
rares pays d'ailleurs à cette dotée
d'une diplomatie féministe portée avec
conviction par Catherine Colonna elle
s'est elle a été lancée notamment lors
du Forum génération égalité en 2021 au
cours duquel ce sont plus de 40
milliards d'euros qui ont été
attribués justement à l'égalité femme
homme un peu partout dans le monde avec
Catherine Colonna une de nos priorités
et d'universaliser la convention
d'Istanbul qui est un des textes
fondateurs des droits des femmes
puisqu'il reconnaît cette violence
structurelle des sociétés à l'égard des
femmes et qu'ils demandent au pays
ratificateur d'agir de des mesures en
termes d'éducation de prévention de
sanctions justement pour protéger les
femmes et les enfants et nous avons
vraiment cette ambition de porter haut
et fort cette convention internationale
par ailleurs nous avons lancé aussi en
2019 un fondation national de soutien
aux organisations féministes dans le
monde j'ai rencontré un certain nombre
de leurs représentante et toutes sont
très satisfaites justement de cette aide
à portée j'ajouterai que la France qui
est ce pays de la Déclaration des Droits
de l'Homme et du Citoyen est aussi le
pays des Droits des Femmes et peut-être
que lorsque elle inscrira dans son texte
le plus élevé c'est à dire la
Constitution le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse peut-être
sera-t-elle aussi un phare pour toutes
les femmes du monde et un signe d'espoir
que nous leur enverrons voilà donc nous
pensons bien sûr à toutes ces femmes et
notre mobilisation est totale pour les
droits des femmes et nous et dans le
monde entier voilà je vous remercie
madame la ministre j'attendais un oui ou
un nom à ma question rien d'autre rien
d'autre nous ne pouvons pas laisser par
notre inaction parce que tout ça est
l'inaction régnait un thème climatereur
renversé femmes envers ces jeunes filles
à travers le monde les courageuses
iraniennes et afghan et toutes les
femmes opprimées combattant de la
liberté moderne de résistance nous donne
une son elles ont besoin de preuves
tangibles de notre soutien ne les
décevons pas ne brisons pas leurs rêves
[Applaudissements]
billon pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues en
cette journée symbolique du 8 mars
journée internationale des droits de la
femme ma question s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre en charge de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes avant-hier un
homme a été placé en garde à vue à
Poitiers il est suspecté d'avoir des
fenestré sa femme deux jours avant
c'était en Gironde qu'un homme
poignardait sa femme depuis le 1er
janvier 26 femmes ont été tuées par leur
conjoint ou ex-conjoints pourtant le
Président de la République a déclaré
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
grandes causes nationales depuis 2017
pourtant un Grenelle sur les violences
conjugales cette nuit en 2019 pourtant
le budget consacré à l'égalité à
sensiblement progresser pourtant le
Parlement a adopté pas moins de quatre
textes de lois mais les chiffres sont là
130 femmes tuées en 2017 10 en 2022 les
personnels restent insuffisamment formés
des drames aurait pu être évités si les
procédures prévues dans la loi avaient
été respectées une plainte pour violence
conjugales doit être immédiatement
transmise au procureur madame la
ministre vous avez récemment présenté le
dispositif qui doit permettre d'aider
les femmes qui sont en situation de
danger à s'extraire des griffes de leur
conjoint violents avant qu'ils ne soient
trop tard permettez-moi de regretter le
manque d'ambition du calendrier de ce
pack nouveau départ un premier test de
trois mois doit être mené dans le
Val-d'Oise avant d'être étendue dans
quatre autres territoires dont seulement
un rural et un ultramarin la
généralisation du pack au niveau
national n'est envisagé que d'ici 2025
ou 2026 si le gouvernement est convaincu
de ce dispositif pourquoi attendre aussi
longtemps avant de le généraliser
pourquoi ne pas accélérer le déploiement
du pack pourquoi risquer la vie de moi
300 femmes
ministre délégué chargé de l'égalité
pour les femmes et les hommes
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la sénatrice Annick Bellon tout d'abord
permettez-moi d'avoir une pensée
effectivement pour toutes ces victimes
les féminicides c'est beaucoup trop et
depuis 2017 beaucoup a été fait
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé que ce
soit en terme de protection des victimes
en termes d'outils de protection le
déploiement massif des téléphones graves
dangers on en a plus de 3000 aujourd'hui
le bracelet anti rapprochement nous
avons considérablement aussi augmenter
les places d'hébergement d'urgence plus
80% formé massivement les policiers les
gendarmes en a 150000 formés donc bien
sûr que nous avons avancé nous allons
aller encore plus loin et effectivement
la première ministre a annoncé dès début
septembre le lancement de ce nouveau
dispositif ce pack nouveau départ pour
aider les victimes à quitter leur
conjoint c'est-à-dire assez extra des
griffes de ce bourreau parce que c'est
difficile de partir quand on a été
pendant des années humilier dévalorisés
harcelés et donc justement l'objectif de
ce pack c'est de pouvoir déclencher pour
elle à certains nombres d'aides
matériels dont elles ont besoin une
allocation ça peut être une allocation
une aide au retour à l'emploi ou à la
formation une aide pour la garde des
enfants un accompagnement psychologique
et si besoin un hébergement d'urgence
l'intérêt de ce dispositif c'est que il
peut être déclenché par tout signalant
c'est-à-dire que ça peut être un
travailleur social un médecin un avocat
un soignant une association qui va
saisir un référent unique à la caisse
d'allocations familiales ou à la CMSA
dans les zones rurales et qui va ensuite
déclencher de manière prioritaire toutes
ces aides 12 semaines d'expérimentation
pour le premier territoire dans le
Val-d'Oise et ensuite il y aura comme
vous l'avez dit 4 autres territoires et
un an au total d'expérimentation il faut
il ne faut pas fabriquer une usine à gaz
mais permettre de répondre le mieux
possible aux besoins des victimes c'est
pour ça qu'il faut un peu de temps merci
la parole est à notre collègue Laurence
Cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain Cyprien écologiste
gagnante de la réforme des retraites le
gouvernement instrumentalisent la cause
des femmes en réalité c'est une réforme
contre les femmes elle ne corrigeant
rien les inégalités salariales de 28 %,
les inégalités de pension de 40 % et
elle monte après votre étude d'impact
que les femmes devront repousser l'âge
auquel elles prennent leur retraite bien
plus tard encore que les hommes vous le
saviez et vous le saviez et vous le
savez donc depuis le début mais ça ne
vous empêche pas de continuer à tenter
de nous vendre le contraire il faut dire
que la majorité sénatoriale vous êtes
bien quelle triste et scandaleux
spectacle de Neyer avec l'utilisation de
l'article 38 du Règlement du Sénat qui a
bâillonné l'opposition avec les droits
avec l'accord des droites Unis
républicain centriste et macronistes
votre réponse votre réforme est bien une
réforme de droite monsieur du soft alors
ma question est simple en ce 8 mars 2023
journée internationale de lutte pour les
droits des femmes allez-vous enfin
sortir du déni et renoncer à votre
réforme qui a mis encore hier des
millions de femmes et d'hommes dans la
rue
pour répondre la parole est au ministre
du Travail Monsieur Olivier du socle
merci beaucoup madame monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Laurence
vous l'avez dit nous sommes le 8 mars
journée internationale des droits des
femmes et vous avez interrogé le
gouvernement sur le contenu de la
réforme des retraites pour ce qui
concerne les femmes nous l'avons voulu
nous l'avons fait madame la Première
ministre l'adier tout à l'heure la
réforme que nous portons apporte un
certain nombre d'améliorations des
améliorations de plusieurs ordres
d'abord vous savez et nous savons tous
que la manière dont nous avons envisagé
de revaloriser les plus petites pensions
sera plus bénéfique aux femmes qu'aux
hommes pourquoi est-ce que ça sera plus
bénéfique aux femmes que hommes parce
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement mais j'y
reviendrai les femmes sont celles qui
ont les plus petites retraites dans
notre pays de la même manière nous
intégrons dans les trimestres retenus
pour calculer l'éligibilité que ce soit
au départ anticipé dans le cadre des
carrières longues que ce soit pour
l'égidité au minimum de pension un
certain nombre de trimestres cotisés au
titre de l'assurance vieillesse pour les
parents au foyer
de la même manière nous sommes ouverts à
un certain nombre d'amendements des
amendements qui n'ont pas pu être
examinés à l'Assemblée nationale qui
sont déposés ici et qui vont permettre
de prendre en compte les indemnités
journalières versées en 2012 pour
relever le niveau de retraite des femmes
qui vont permettre aussi d'améliorer la
situation des femmes et des parents au
sens le plus large sur des sujets
parfois très sensibles je pense
notamment aux devenir du calcul des
pensions de retraite en cas de perte
d'un enfant pour les familles qui ont
plus de 3 enfants votre assemblée est
saisie d'un certain nombre de
propositions notamment des propositions
portées par le président retaille ou
permettant de surcoter les trimestres
acquis par les femmes une fois qu'elles
ont atteint la durée d'affiliation crise
et avant l'âge d'ouverture des droits et
je peux vous assurer que cette
proposition a un équilibre qu'il faut
regarder et qu'il faut regarder avec je
crois le plus d'ouverture d'esprit
possible et enfin Madame la présidente
madame la sénatrice pardonnez-moi ce
n'est pas la première fois que je vous
qualifie ainsi vous avez rappelé que
nous sommes le 8 mars et peut-être
puisque vous avez gardé un certain temps
pour me répondre peut-être que nous
pourrons convenir ensemble en cette
journée internationale des droits des
femmes que la vraie inégalité de pension
elle ne n’est pas de notre système de
retraite elle n'est des inégalités
professionnelles et que c'est sur le
chantier de l'égalité professionnelle
tout au long de la vie que nous devons
porter tous nos efforts pour que les
pensions soient les mêmes entre les
femmes et les hommes
[Applaudissements]
avec vous monsieur le ministre le 8 mars
et la journée du recul des droits des
femmes ce que vous nous avez dit ce sont
des contre-vérités la seule chose avec
laquelle je suis d'accord c'est qu'il
faudrait effectivement une grande loi
travail et l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes c'est bête fin aux inégalités
salariales revaloriser les métiers
féminisés notamment les aides-soignantes
les auxiliaires de vie tous les métiers
du soin et du lien ainsi que les
personnels de propreté qui ont manifesté
ce matin devant le Sénat faire cotiser à
temps plein les emplois à temps partiel
augmenter le taux d'emploi des femmes
autant d'argent pour les caisses de
sécurité sociale ça permettrait de
renflouer votre soi-disant déficit juste
qui justifie votre projet régressif
voilà une réforme de justice et
d'égalité pour les femmes une réforme
féministe en ce 8 mars les femmes sont
dans la rue pour le crier le peuple est
encore dans la rue que ça vous plaise ou
que ça ne vous plaise pas et ils vont
toutes et tous dire non aux deux ans de
vie que vous voulez leur voler
pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Hervé Berville
secrétaire d'État chargé de la mer la
place des océans dans l'agenda politique
international n'est pas à la mesure de
leur rôle dans les équilibres
planétaires il y a un an à Brest c'est
le constat que dressait le président de
la République en conclusion du premier
Sommet mondial qui leur était dédié un
rassemblement inédit des dirigeants
mondiaux organisés dans le cadre de la
présidence française du Conseil de
l'Union européenne avec cette volonté
d'accélérer à cette occasion avait été
lancé une coalition de près de 50 états
réaffirmant leur objectif parvenir enfin
après des années de négociation à un
texte contraignant sur la gouvernance de
la haute mer pour mieux la protéger
c'est désormais chose faite après celui
de décembre un deuxième accord de la
plus haute importance a été conclue ce 4
mars à New York sous l'égide de l'ONU il
vient acter le futur traité
international sur l'utilisation durable
de la conservation de la biodiversité en
haute mer les mesures qui figurent ont
été jugées essentielles pour nos
écosystèmes avec notamment la création
désormais entérinée d'air marine
protégée et je profite de cette prise de
parole pour saluer une nouvelle fois ici
les travaux menés par nos collègues
tevaro fridge et Michel Canevet sur les
fonds marins notre groupe tient à saluer
cette avancée majeure dans la protection
de nos océans puis de carbone essentiel
à la régulation climatique et à la lutte
contre le réchauffement nous saluons le
rôle actif joué par la France dans cette
recherche d'un accord mondial monsieur
le secrétaire d'État pourriez-vous
détailler les avancées portées par ce
traité essentiel et les actions qu'il
reste amener pour la mise en oeuvre
concrète de cette instrument
international juridiquement contraignant
je vous remercie la parole est au
secrétaire d'État
en charge de la mère Monsieur Hervé
Berville monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice avait d'abord je me
permets de vous remercier pour
engagement pour la préservation des
océans celle de votre groupe et celle
également du sénateur Teva Road vous
l'avez dit dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche les États membres des Nations
Unies ont conclu un accord sur la
protection de la biodiversité marine en
haute mer qui est un espace qui est
situé à 370 km des côtes ce n'est pas le
fruit du hasard il y a plus d'un an le
président de la République et l'Union
européenne ont relancé ce texte qui
était enlisé depuis 15 ans c'est un
tournant majeur pour la protection des
océans puisque c'est un traité qui est
juridiquement contraignant et qui
préserve un espace qui recouvre 45% de
la surface de la planète alors ce traité
est décisif pour au moins trois raisons
la première c'est qu'il oblige les États
à avoir des études d'impact
environnemental pour toute nouvelle
activité en haute mer la deuxième raison
c'est qu'il ouvre la voie à la création
très concrète d'air marine protégée en
haute mer et puis la troisième qui est
une raison et qui montre à quel point
c'est un traité historique c'est que
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
des négociations environnementales les
décisions ne seront plus prises aux
consensus qui permettaient à des Data de
bloquer mais à la majorité ce qui
permettra d'établir partout des aires
protégées à la majorité et donc ne pas
dans notre processus de blocage quels
sont les prochaines étapes la première
c'est l'entrée en vigueur il faudra que
60 états le ratifient pour qu'il entre
en vigueur et notre objectif c'est que
d'ici le sommet des Nations Unies pour
les océans qui se tiendra en France en
2025 à Nice nous puissions avoir une
entrée en vigueur le deuxième c'est de
poursuivre le combat sur la protection
des océans et donc la France continuera
à mobiliser pour notamment
l'interdiction de l'exploitation minière
des grands fonds marins qui a un combat
essentiel et donc vous voyez nous ne
pourrons pas gagner le course
contre-la-montre climatique si nous ne
protégeons pas les océans si nous ne
présentons pas la haute mer et c'est
tout l'intérêt de ce traité qui a été
conclu par les États membres des Nations
Unies je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Alain
jouant des pour le groupe les
républicain
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la Première ministre la France
libératrice du Mali est chassé d'Afrique
quasiment sans préavis
Centrafrique Burkina Faso etc
la France est grande puissance
diplomatique qui a normalement
l'engage
universel qui doit parler à tout le
monde cette France se fâche avec ses
partenaires la même réussie à se fâcher
en même temps il faut le faire avec le
Maroc et l'Algérie
on est donc face à un échec diplomatique
cuisant dramatique pour l'avenir
j'allais vous demander quel est votre
politique pour l'Afrique mais le
président de la République a déclaré le
27 février qui avait plus de politique
française en Afrique alors est-ce vrai
pour vos réponses la parole est à la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères Madame Catherine Colonna
madame la ministre merci Monsieur
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur je
connais votre intérêt pour l'Afrique
mais voyez-vous depuis quelques temps
l'Afrique a changé et la France aussi a
changé l'Afrique a changé elle est
depuis un certain temps mais je suis sûr
que l'ancien ministre s'en est souvenu
l'Afrique est pour les décennies qui
viennent une terre de croissance une
terre d'opportunités une terre de
création le présent de la République a
pu le constater par exemple lors de son
déplacement la semaine dernière auprès
des entrepreneurs et des artistes réunis
à l'Institut français de Kinshasa et
l'Afrique qui a changé aussi monsieur
sénateur parce que elle n'entend pas à
se faire dicter par l'extérieur ce qui
est bon pour elle les pays africains
défendent leurs intérêts avec raison et
nous le faisons tous mais la France
aussi a changé et nous voulons sortir
des visions datées l'Afrique les pays
africains car il y a plusieurs Afrique
vous le savez bien ne sont pas
spectateurs d'une concurrence entre
puissance nous avons sur ce continent
des partenaires des défis communs et des
atouts à utiliser nos liens humains nos
diaspora nos entrepreneurs nos
universités ne résout culturels et le
dynamisme de nos jeunesses et la France
a changé aussi parce qu'elle met en
place des outils pour développer ses
nouveaux partenariat alors nous savons
aussi qu'il nous faut lutter davantage
contre la désinformation contre les
manipulations de l'information et nous
savons aussi quels sont les forces qui
sont à l'oeuvre pour avancer dans une
stratégie qui certainement ne fera pas
avancer ni la paix ni la stabilité ni la
prospérité des pays considérés et c'est
en additionnant toutes ces actions que
nous resterons un partenaire actif sur
ce continent dans notre intérêt dans
celui de nos peuples et dans l'intérêt
de l'Europe également
monsieur joyeux
oui merci madame la ministre je crois
surtout que si les choses ont changé la
France doit reprendre son destin en main
en Afrique comme ailleurs nous refusons
d'ailleurs suite à la déclaration
franco-américaine de mois de novembre
2022 une éventuelle un éventuel
copilotage de nos bases en Afrique avec
nos alliés des États-Unis d'Amérique la
France suffisamment grande pour
s'occuper d'une vraie politique en
Afrique vous avez des moyens à votre
disposition madame la ministre vous
savez que nous disposons quand même de
ces bases prépositionnées en Afrique les
accords ont été renégociés en 2010 ils
sont très vivants ils sont utiles c'est
pas la peine de vouloir tout casser les
déclarations que nous avons entendues
sont particulièrement inquiétantes vous
avez un corps diplomatique qu'il
faudrait protéger au lieu de le casser
qui est exceptionnel et avec lequel
et avec lequel nous avons défini nous
avons défini une ligne très claire pour
l'Afrique très intelligente ni ingérence
ni des daim nous ne laissons pas tomber
mais en même temps nous ne sommes pas
effectivement des colonialistes nous
devons combattre cette idée le président
de la République ne doit pas laisser
dire que la France est un État
néo-colonialiste c'est vraiment
l'honneur de la France et notre image
nous ne devons plus être humiliés sur
tous ces sujets madame la ministre je
conclus surtout ces sujets madame la
ministre le Sénat la commission des
affaires étrangères peut vous aider avec
le président avec le président Cambon
nous vous demandons ici un débat
parlementaire merci
la parole est à notre collègue Monique
Lubin pour le gros socialiste écologique
et républicain
merci monsieur le président
cette réforme protège les femmes qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt les femmes qui
sont dans les métiers difficiles les
femmes qui ont dû interrompre leur
carrière ces propos sont de vous madame
la Première ministre et vous venez
d'ailleurs de l'héréérer aujourd'hui
j'ai une pensée pour les femmes que je
connais dans mon département des Landes
où l'industrie agroalimentaire est très
présente et plus particulièrement je
pense à cette femme qui avait témoignée
lors d'un important mouvement de grève
dans une entreprise de transformation
agroalimentaire de mon département et
qui avait raconté qu'elle se levait à 4
heures du matin pour aller travailler
dans une sur une chaîne d'éviterration
de volailles à plusieurs kilomètres de
chez elle pour un salaire à peine
supérieur au SMIC après de nombreuses
années d'ancienneté vous voyez madame la
ministre tous les critères que vous avez
cités sont réunis ici j'aimerais que
vous m'expliquiez comment ce projet de
loi va améliorer la future retraite de
cette salarié
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du socle mais du
travail du plein d'emploi de l'insertion
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
signatrice Lubin si j'ai bien écouté
votre question vous avez pris l'exemple
d'une femme je travaille dans une
industrie agroalimentaire sur une chaîne
de préparation de volaille donc un
travail physique et si j'ai bien compris
aussi un travail posté avec des départs
extrêmement tôt et vous nous dites
qu'est-ce qui est dans votre projet de
loi va permettre d'aider cette femme
dans notre projet de loi ce qui va
permettre d'aider cette femme c'est
qu'au titre de la pénibilité nous allons
améliorer le compte professionnel de
prévention nous allons diminuer de 50 à
30 le nombre de travail postés qu'il
faut faire pour obtenir des points au
titre de la pénibilité si cette même
femme est exposée simultanément à la
fois des températures qui peuvent être
extrêmement basses dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire mais aussi exposer à des
aspects de manutention particulièrement
pénible ou à des travaux de nuit elle
pourra aussi obtenir plus de points
grâce à notre projet de loi et si vous
votez cet article 9
je suis professionnel à laquelle elle
appartient celle de l'agroalimentaire
sera tenue obligée de négocier un accord
de prévention de la pénibilité nous
allons co-financer à hauteur de 1
milliard d'euros et les postures
pénibles les vibrations le port de
charge lourdes seront prises en charge
et lui permettront à la fois de
bénéficier de prévention de formation de
reconversion mais aussi d'un suivi
médical renforcé le cas échéant si
malheureusement l'usure professionnelle
fait son œuvre la possibilité d'un
départ anticipé vous avez dit madame la
sénatrice que cette femme a travaillé
toute sa vie pour un niveau de salaire
très proche du SMIC grâce à notre projet
de loi et grâce au relèvement du minimum
contributif et donc des pensions les
plus basses nous allons pouvoir l'aider
à partir avec ton retraite meilleure que
si cette fois cette réforme n'était pas
votée et puis peut-être madame la
sénatrice que cette même femme si elle
ressemble à celle que je connais dans
mon département de l'Ardèche peut-être
qu'elle a commencé à travailler
extrêmement tôt et grâce à notre effort
elle va pouvoir partir aussi plutôt
parce que nous protégeons les carrières
longues vous sénatrices il y a un
article sur l'âge d'ouverture des droits
sur lequel nous sommes en train de
discuter et le débat reprendra tout à
l'heure mais après cet article une fois
l'obstruction que vous essayez de mettre
en place sera surmonté nous pourrons
peut-être nous intéresser à ce que dans
cette loi permettra à cette femme d'être
protégée madame Lubin
monsieur le ministre je savais que vous
m'apporteriez une réponse parfaite
claire formatée en appui j'ai dit
formater on appuie sur le bouton et tout
sort il y a pas de souci vous parlez
vous parlez des critères de pénibilité
une fois de plus je ferai remarqué que
c'est ce que vous avez enlevé nous
avions mis de véritables critères de
pénibilité vous vous êtes empressé de
les enlever vous parliez des carrières
longues oui mais si cette femme n'a pas
eu la chance de commencer à travailler
juste avant 18 ans elle travaillera
quand même deux ans de plus c'est-à-dire
de 62 à 64 ans ce que ce que je voulais
dire surtout ce que je voulais dire
surtout c'est que lorsque l'annonce a
été faite de cette réforme vous avez
cherché les uns et les autres à
instrumentaliser la cause des femmes
pour mieux vendre votre projet de loi
mais les économistes qui se sont penchés
sur la question ont immédies
immédiatement démonter tout cela et
enfin je terminerai comme
exprimé ces derniers jours madame
Violaine Lucas présidente de
l'association choisir la cause des
femmes et sur un tout autre registre
celui de l'hommage rendu à Gisèle à la
limite je veux moi aussi vous rappeler
que les femmes ne veulent plus
construirementaliser qu'il s'agisse des
ouvrières des Landes ou de celles qui
combattent en mémoire des plus grandes
comme Gisèle Halimi
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Sol pour
le groupe les républicains
j'appelle tout le monde à respecter le
temps
[Applaudissements]
si le président mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues madame
la ministre alors que l'encadrement par
la loire-est de la rémunération de
l'intérim médical dans le secteur public
va entrer en application à partir du 3
avril une vive inquiétude monte de d'un
peu partout en France des ruptures
d'activité se profilent fermeture des
services d'urgence fermeture de
maternité fermeture des services de
chirurgie fragilisation de la réducation
médicale et des Samus tout cela par
marque de médecins cette décision dont
je comprends il partage la finalité va
créer dans les territoires une situation
extrêmement difficile qui va accroître
un peu plus encore l'inégalité des
Français face à l'accès aux soins
conscient des difficultés qui
s'annoncent et qui inquiète est
désormais de très nombreux élus locaux
vous avez demandé aux ARS d'animer des
concertations locales territoire par
territoire avec les préfets les élus
pour affiner les diagnostics
établissements par établissement vous
avez souhaité que les ARS construisent
des solutions avec les professionnels de
santé du territoire mais également avec
les centres hospitaliers universitaires
et des établissements sièges de
groupement de territoires vous avez
enfin rappelé que les établissements
privés s'étaient engagés à suivre le
gouvernement sur la voie d'une
rémunération raisonnée est suffisant si
cela ne l'est pas envisagez-vous
détendre cette régulation pensez-vous
madame la ministre que vous instructions
suffiront à répondre à la pénurie qui se
profile pouvez-vous nous en dire plus
sur le résultat du travail que vous avez
confié aux ARS car il y a désormais
urgences le Ségur de la santé faute de
s'être atelier une réforme en profondeur
d'une autre système de santé le rend
définitive rien réglé à une situation de
plus en plus difficile quelle est Madame
la Ministre votre plan d'action pour
assurer la permanence des soins pour
redonner confiance au système public et
libéral de santé pour que le statut des
praticiens hospitaliers salariés à
l'hôpital soit attractif et que la
question de l'intérim ne se pose plus
pondre à la parole à la ministre des
chargée de l'organisation territoriale
et des professions de santé
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur les
sénateurs sol tout d'abord comme vous
l'avez dit je tiens à rappeler que la
régulation de l'intérim c'est une
volonté constante du législateur et
d'ailleurs cela s'est traduit dans deux
lois lors des deux dernières mandatures
précédentes en effet nous assistons à
certains endroits à une dérive qui ne
sont plus acceptable et qui aura de
l'éthique même des soignants quelques
chiffres en 2021 l'intérim c'est 359
millions d'euros de dépenses avec des
rémunérations individuelles qui
pouvaient atteindre 5000 euros
journalier ce n'est tout simplement pas
soutenable et cela déstabilise les
équipes de soins avec des effectifs
tournants instables et qui créent de
l'injustice même entre les
professionnels face à ces dérives le
législateur à agi et vie souscrit je
rappelle d'ailleurs que la loi de 2016
plafonnée de l'intérim à 1170 euros brut
pour une mission de 24 heures ce qui est
loin d'être négligeable cela ne permet
de conserver de l'attractivité pour
l'intérim car il n'est bien entendu pas
question de supprimer tout recours à
l'intérim mais bien de lutter contre
certaines dérives autour de cette
la loi riste qui devait rentrer en
vigueur en octobre 2021 du fait de la
crise sanitaire nous avons dû en décaler
cette mise en oeuvre et comme vous
l'avez souligné rentrera en compte à
partir du 3 avril vous avez eu aussi la
gentillesse de souligner que nous avons
anticipé cette cette perspective de la
rentrée en œuvre de cette loi et nous
avons demandé aux ARS un travail
établissement par établissement pour
remonter toutes les problématiques les
ARS avaient jusqu'à lundi soir pour nous
faire remonter toutes les problématiques
de terrain et nous suivons chacune de
ces situations locales avec une très
grande attention nous en rappelons aussi
au secteur privé qui doit prendre ses
responsabilités et jouer aussi le jeu de
l'éthique c'est tous ensemble que nous y
arriverons monsieur le sénateur vous le
voyez nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
pour accompagner les territoires mettre
fin à ses dérives inacceptables et
compter sur notre engagement aux côtés
des ARS pour apporter des réponses
territoire par territoire établissement
par établissement
mesdam et la ministre seul un capteur
précis et partagé en matière de
coopération entre les établissements de
santé publique et privés médecine de
ville ARS représentant des usagers élus
territoriaux et une dose de
reconnaissance permettra sur la base
d'une participation imposée à tous les
acteurs privés et publics d'assurer une
accessibilité à des soins de qualité 24
heures sur 24 sur tout le territoire
national je vous remercie merci la
parole est à notre collègue Claude Kern
pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues madame la ministre des Sports
l'un des refrains refrains de la
communication du comité d'organisation
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris 2024 et de faire de ces jeux un
succès populaire et accessible à tous le
président du cojob Tony estanguay dont
je salue par ailleurs le travail c'est
lui-même félicité de la liesse suscité
par la perspective de cet événement
international populaire tout en
rappelant que les recettes de la
billetterie sont indispensables à
l'équilibre des comptes parmi la
pourtant la réalité est tout autre
l'ouverture de la billetterie à l'issue
du tirage au sort s'avère loin du succès
avéré en effet entre la rigidité des
formules proposées notamment le système
de pack un choix limité avec beaucoup
d'inconnus et surtout des tarifs jugés
prohibitifs le compte n'y est pas pour
une famille passionnée de sport et qui
rêvait d'assister à des épreuves la
facture peut vite grimper à plusieurs
milliers d'euros
nous sommes bien loin des tarifs
populaires sur lesquels une grosse
communication a été faite en creusant un
peu nous apprenons par ailleurs que la
moitié des billets à 24 euros ne seront
pas mises en vente car réservé par
l'État pour être distribué à des jeunes
et des associations c'est fort louable
mais comprenez que cela a de quoi créer
une réelle frustration de plus les
études comparatives avec les jeux
précédents semblent montrer que les
tarifs de cette édition sont plus élevés
madame la ministre comment expliquer à
des spectateurs spacieux que les Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 ne vont avoir
de populaire que le nom que comptez-vous
faire pour que cette GOP que nous
attendons depuis 100 ans en France soit
réellement l'événement populaire annoncé
et que nous souhaitons tous comment
comptez-vous lutter contre le sentiment
actuel d'exclusion au bénéfice des
valeurs de participation et de
regroupement prônés par l'olympisme
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre des Sports et des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
Madame le Ministre merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur monsieur le sénateur Claude
Kern
vous soulignez à juste titre à
l'importance de cette dimension
d'accessibilité tarifaire de la
billetterie pour les jeux et par là
aussi la nécessité pour notre pays
d'organiser une grande fête populaire à
tous les coins de ce pays alors moi je
voudrais évidemment d'abord dire que ce
principe d'accessibilité tarifaire on y
est tous extraordinairement attaché
rappelez quelques éléments d'abord le
fait que dans les billets qui ont été
mis en vente les 8 millions de billets
qui sont mis en vente par et pour le
grand public par le comité
d'organisation je voudrais vraiment
rappeler que 1 million sont à un prix
d'entrée de 24 euros et ce pour tous les
sports et que 4 millions la moitié sont
à moins de 50 euros évidemment pour que
certains biais soient attractifs il faut
que d'autres soient des tarifs plus
élevés mais le comité d'organisation
éveillé ce qu'il n'y ait pas plus de 10%
des billets qui soient à plus de 200
euros la lignée
ces prix sont dans la lignée des
éditions des billets pardon des éditions
c'est très important de le rappeler et
je voudrais aussi souligner c'est aussi
mon rôle de ministre des Sports que ce
spectacle réunit les athlètes les plus
exceptionnels du monde à un moment de
grande fête tous les quatre ans pour
obtenir le sésame lui-même le plus
important du monde et que ces jeux ils
doivent être autofinancés ils le sont
sur des fonds privés pour le volley
olympique donc des recettes de
billetterie qui sont importantes mais
moi je veux vraiment rappeler cet
engouement suscité par cette étape de
billetterie les Français se sont
fortement mobilisés 50% des acheteurs
sur 112 nationalités recensées et je ne
veux pas opposer la billetterie
territoriale et la billetterie populaire
qui comme vous l'avez dit viendront
compléter ce volet là en permettant aux
collectivités hautes et demain aux
collectivités terre de jeu de proposer
une billetterie accessible pour leur
public et à l'état d'offrir un certain
nombre de billets à la jeunesse aux
personnes en situation de handicap ainsi
qu'aux bénévoles du mouvement sportif
nous voulons être et nous serons tous
ensemble au rendez-vous de
l'accessibilité tarifaire et d'une
grande fête populaire
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Martin décidera pour le groupe
les républicains
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 14
février le Parlement européen votait
l'interdiction de la commercialisation
des véhicules à moteur thermique à
compter de 2035 le 1er mars se vote
devait être entériné mais il a été
reporté au 7 mars c'est-à-dire hier et
depuis reporté à cinédié on cause le
blocage de l'Allemagne de l'Italie de la
Pologne et de la Bulgarie la voiture
électrique est une mobilité décarbonée
silencieuse et confortable bref de
l'innovation technologique mais
aujourd'hui Monsieur le Ministre la
voiture électrique c'est aussi hélas un
recyclage insatisfaisant des batteries
dont à peine 46% sont collectés et
d'ailleurs nos collègues ultramarins
pourraient témoigner des problèmes
environnementaux que ces batteries
soulèvent dans leur territoire la
voiture électrique c'est aussi une
menace pour notre souveraineté
industrielle plus de 80% des batteries
sont importées d'Asie
un facteur d'inégalité territoriale
également monsieur le ministre puisque
l'ADEME juge surtout bénéfique l'impact
carbone de la voiture électrique pour
les trajets en ville et dans le cas de
véhicules citadins monsieur le ministre
à ce stade la voiture électrique n'a pas
pleinement démontré sa vertu écologique
ni sa pertinence pour la stratégie
industrielle de la France
quelle est la position de la France en
boîte à tel la position de l'Allemagne
de l'Italie de la Pologne et de la
Bulgarie je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre
déléguée en charge des transports
monsieur Beaune
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Marta de Sidra comme la
rappelait à l'instant à Christophe Béchu
des engagements ont été pris par la
France par l'Allemagne et par l'ensemble
des États européens c'était d'ailleurs
en grande partie sous-présidente
française de l'Union européenne et
toutes les préoccupations que vous
exprimez sont parfaitement fondées mais
aujourd'hui l'alternative est assez
simple refusons-nous ou reportons-nous
cette échéance de 2035 pour la fin de la
vente des véhicules thermiques pas leur
utilisation en général mais leur vente
ou donnons-nous les moyens de réussir
cette grande ambition écologique et
industrielle par une production en
France et en Europe ces résoluments
cette seconde voie que nous devons
prendre car sinon dans une décennie à
peine nous nous retrouverions ici nous
ou d'autres pour regretter que la France
et l'Europe n'est pas pris le virage que
toutes les grandes puissances
économiques industrielles notamment les
États-Unis notamment la Chine sont en
train de prendre et sur lesquels elles
sont en train d'accélérer nous devons
donc relever ce défi il est absolument
considérable et j'ai hier soir à sa
demande avec mon homologue allemand au
ministre des Transports qui portent
cette préoccupation un peu nouvelle et
comme la vie Christophe Béchu légèrement
lié à des considérations de politique
intérieure pour que nous rappelions
ensemble nos engagements pour relever le
défi pour relever le défi que devant
nous faire nous devons d'abord avoir des
véhicules accessibles en effet pour tous
les Françaises et tous les Françaises et
tous les Français c'est absolument
essentiel c'est ce que nous faisons par
des aides importantes et il est vrai que
malgré ses aides encore aujourd'hui
souvent le véhicule électrique est un
produit trop cher parfois un produit de
luxe mais nous devons poursuivre dans
cette voie développer aussi nos bornes
électriques par les aides que nous
déployons si nous
renoncions maintenant ce serait un
formidable gâchis aussi de l'argent du
contribuable que nous avons investi et
puis c'est un défi industriel qu'il faut
relever nous le faisons avec Bruno Le
Maire en particulier avec Roland Lescure
parce que nous pouvons et nos
constructeurs sont engagés pour produire
en France et en Europe des véhicules
électriques plus abordables souverain
dans les années qui viennent eux-mêmes
nous demandent de tenir ce cap car sinon
ce serait un échec écologique et un
échec industriel pour la France et pour
l'Europe nous devons et nous pouvons
relever ce défi tous ensemble
monsieur le ministre j'observe en fait
que certains de nos partenaires savent
défendre leur intérêts mieux que
d'autres puisque vous avez cité
l'Allemagne mais l'Allemagne justement
fait partie de ces pays qui ne sont pas
d'accord aujourd'hui avec la date de
2035 et au pays de stellantiste et de
Renault je n'ai aucun doute sur la
capacité de notre industrie automobile
de relever ce défi là simplement ce que
je dis c'est que aujourd'hui vous vous
êtes engagé dans un accord de 2035 qui
me semble parfaitement prématuré au
regard des enjeux industriels justement
pour notre pays et aux enjeux
environnementaux qui sont très prégnants
dans nos territoires donc j'espère
monsieur le ministre nous entendrez cet
appel de nos territoires je vous
remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Marie-Pierre Monnier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en 2001 la loi
ouvrir a obligatoire trois séances
d'éducation à la sexualité au cours
d'une année scolaire ces séances sont un
outil indispensable au dévoilement des
stéréotypes sexistes à la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes à la
compréhension du consentement et à la
prévention contre les pratiques
sexuelles à risque auprès des jeunes en
cette journée internationale des droits
des femmes je vous rappelle que le
dernier rapport du Haut Conseil égalité
sur l'état des lieux du sexisme en
France a révélé une recrudescence du
sexisme chez les jeunes hommes 25%
d'entre eux pensent qu'il faut parfois
être violent dans une relation amoureuse
contre 11% tous âges confondus il est
plus que jamais indispensable d'agir et
notre premier levier c'est d'appliquer
la loi fin 2020 pendant l'examen du PLF
2021 j’allerte Blanquet monsieur
Blanquer car de nombreuses associations
signalent la non tenue des séances dans
certains établissements le Sénat adopte
mon amendement qui prévoyait d'augmenter
le budget dédié à l'organisation de des
séances pour que leur mise en oeuvre
soit effective Jean-Michel Blanquer
m'avait alors rétorqué qu'il n'y avait
pas de problème et la mesure avait été
supprimée à l'Assemblée pourtant il y a
quelques mois nous apprenions qu'un
rapport de l'inspection générale de
l'éducation nationale révèle que à
l'école primaire et au lycée moins de
15% des élèves bénéficient de ces trois
séances moins de 20% au collège partout
je vais sur le terrain des enseignants
des associations féministes des
gendarmes Malherbes sur le fait que ces
séances n'ont pas lieu le Haut Conseil
l'égalité demande un plan d'urgence pour
la mise en oeuvre effective de ces
séances et la semaine dernière trois
associations le planning familial SOS
Homophobie et Sidaction ont décidé
d'attaquer l'État en justice pour vous
mettre devant vos responsabilités elle
gagneront car elles ont raison ma
question est donc la suivante
pouvez-vous enfin reconnaître madame la
ministre que la loi n'est pas appliquée
et nous indiquer ce que vous prévoyez
pour y remédier
on vous répond de la parole est à la
ministre déléguée chargée de
l'entiellement de la formation
professionnelle madame Grandjean merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice aujourd'hui en cette journée
internationale des droits des femmes au
fond là vous posez une question sur
l'éducation à la sexualité qui concerne
toutes et tous puis comme garçon vous
l'avez dit c'est une mission du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale qui a
été mise en place par la loi du 4
juillet 2001 et depuis effectivement
chaque année trois séances d'éducation à
la sexualité adaptée à leurs âges
doivent pouvoir être dispensés aux
élèves le ministre d'éducation nationale
que j'excuse aujourd'hui dès son arrivée
à lancer une enquête de manière à voir
la réalité de ces cours et de leur
dispensation dans l'ensemble des
territoires si il a également réalisé
deux circulaires aux inspecteurs de
l'éducation nationale et au chef
d'établissement pour que ses cours
soient effectivement dispensé il s'avère
qu'effectivement des progrès doivent
pouvoir être fait en la matière c'est
tout le sens de du plan interministériel
lancé par madame la Première ministre
qui notamment dans son axe 4 à prévoir à
renforcement de l'éducation à la
sexualité qui vient accompagner la
culturation aux enjeux c'est tout le
sens également de ce qui est lancé dans
ce plan au travers d'une enquête
annuelle de la de la réalité des actions
mises en oeuvre ainsi qu'un plan de
formation du personnel de l'éducation
nationale vous évoquez les trois
associations qui attaquent l'État pour
la non mise en oeuvre de cette loi de
2001 je m'en étonne permettez-moi car ce
sont des actions qui interviennent dans
nos établissements qui travaillent avec
nous et que pour certaines nous
finançons elles ont bien sûr le droit de
se recourt mais je tiens à dire que nous
n'avons pas attendu pour nous engager
sur le sujet c'est une grande cause
portée par le Président de la République
et un plan à nouveau lancé pour 2027 par
madame la Première ministre bien la
parole est à notre collègue Guillaume
Chevrollier pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre les
importants épisode de sécheresse de
l'été dernier n'était finalement que les
prémices d'une pénurie qui s'installe
désormais dans la durée à ce jour nous
avons deux mois de retard sur la
recharge des nappes phréatiques une
sécheresse hivernale inédite l'accès à
l'eau potable que l'on croyait garantie
à tous nos concitoyens est aujourd'hui
menacés d'autant plus que nous
constatons la réduction des débits des
cours d'eau qui entraîne une
concentration des micropolluants et pose
un vrai problème sanitaire pour la
potabilité de l'eau au-delà de nos
concitoyens la tension sur l'eau a bien
entendu un impact sur le fonctionnement
de nos entreprises de notre agriculture
les cultures l'élevage mais aussi nos
centrales nucléaires le Sénat a mené un
certain nombre de travaux autour de
cette problématique en présentant
plusieurs pistes pour améliorer notre
gestion de l'eau que ce soit la
conciliation des usages la
sensibilisation du grand public à la
sobriété les retenus d'eau ou la
nécessaire modernisation de l'irrigation
pour nos agriculteurs les propositions
ne manquent pas mais elles ont besoin de
financement monsieur le ministre dans ce
contexte qui nous préoccupe tous
plusieurs départements ont déjà été
placés en situation d'alerte sécheresse
mais il est évident que le temps n'est
plus à la réaction mais à l'anticipation
indispensable et à l'adaptation de notre
pays au changement climatique monsieur
le ministre ma question est simple
pouvez-vous nous exposer de façon très
concrète votre politique
d'anticipation sur l'eau à défaut
d'avoir anticipé la crise de l'énergie
le gouvernement prendra-t-il toutes les
mesures nécessaires afin de faire face à
la crise de l'eau
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes de la transition écologique
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Guillaume Chevrollier
cette plus de 700 communes privées d'eau
potable l'été dernier et 1260 cours
d'eau qui ont été en rupture
d'écoulement compte tenu de l'épisode de
sécheresse qu'on a connu et à la fin de
l'été un niveau des nappes
particulièrement bas et la période de
recharge jusqu'à ce début de semaine non
seulement n'a pas permis de recharger
c'est la mais compte tenu du mois de
février que nous avons connu la même
aggraver et donc le chiffre que vous
donnez de ces deux mois de retard en
moyenne sur les nappes phréatiques est
une réalité depuis 24 heures nous avons
des épisodes de pluie abondants qui
malheureusement ne concerneront pas le
pourtour méditerranéen et le couloir
rodanien on peut penser et espérer que
sur une large partie nord du pays on
devrait avoir des pluies qui permettront
au niveau de recharge mais quand on dit
de moins de retard c'est pas de moindre
retard par rapport à la moyenne c'est
deux mois de retard par rapport à la
situation d'avant l'été 2022 ce qui
explique la préoccupation qui est la
nôtre
l'anticipation l'adaptation en matière
de changement climatique ce que nous
disent des experts c'est qu'on pourrait
avoir entre 10 et 40% de volume de pluie
en moins et avec parfois des épisodes
trop pluvieux pour permettre une
recharge des nappes dans de bonnes
conditions parce que si la pluie est
trop forte en particulier si on se
préoccupe pas de lutter contre
l'artificialisation en faisant en sorte
de pouvoir permettre la recharger nappes
si on se préoccupe pas de la
perméabilité des sols on aggra une
partie de ce de cette situation à très
court terme réunion d'un comité
anticipation sécheresse des 23 février
réunion des préfets de bassin de 27
réunions de tous les préfets lundi
dernier pour dire partout prenez dès
maintenant des mesures qu'on prend
habituellement plus tard si la situation
justifie la suite dans quelques jours le
plan o plus de 50 mesures nous nous
sommes inspirés des travaux du Sénat
comme tout était écrit j'ai pas conduit
des auditions avec mes collègues pour
entendre les uns et les autres mais on a
lu avec beaucoup d'attention les
rapports sur les mesures qui étaient
préconisées et vous retrouverez une
partie de votre pâte ou de vos enquêtes
dans ce qui sera présenté qui traitera
de quantité de qualité et de gouvernance
l'enjeu il est devant nous il nécessite
une union sacrée parce que vous l'avez
dit l'eau c'est la vie et l'eau c'est
nécessaire pour l'agriculture pour
l'industrie et bien sûr pour nos
concitoyens
monsieur chevrolier oui merci monsieur
le ministre de vous inspirer les travaux
du Sénat effectivement dans cette crise
de l'eau le soutien financier au
collectivités locales est indispensable
elles ont la connaissance et la maîtrise
du terrain et seront trouvées les
solutions les plus adaptées pour une eau
comme vous l'avez dit en quantité et en
qualité et avec les éventuels mesures de
restriction le gouvernement doit
informer de façon transparente j'ose
dire limpide afin de permettre
l'acceptibilité des contraintes
la parole
est à notre collègue Michel cadavet pour
le groupe de l'Union centriste merci
monsieur le président madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues la France est
un grand pays maritime et nous tenons à
ce qu'ils demeure mais c'est vrai que la
filière halieutique connaît de
nombreuses difficultés de nombreux
inquiétudes il y a notamment le PAI qui
va sortir
90 navires de la flotte française il y a
aussi les inquiétudes liées au carburant
puisque l'équilibre économique de
nombreux armements et mis en inquiétude
donc il convient de d'y apporter des
solutions là aussi et puis les pêcheurs
en ont marre en quelque sorte d'être
culpabilisé par les prises d'accessoires
de dauphins la population de dauphins
notamment à largement augmenté dans le
seuil Atlantique et à chaque fois qu'il
y en a sur le littoral on montre du
doigt les pêcheurs mais la principale
source d'inquiétude de Mesdames et
Messieurs c'est notamment le projet
d'interdiction du chalutage qui a été
proposé par la Commission européenne
voilà quelques jours et ce dans les
aires protégées
l'inquiétude est forte parce que
imagine-t-on demain qu'on ne puisse plus
aller pêcher les coquilles Saint-Jacques
en baisse Saint-Brieuc imagine-t-on
demain qu'on ne puisse plus non plus
manger les langoustines ou la lotte au
large de déglenant imagine-t-on encore
qu'on ne puisse plus manger les les
huîtres de pleine mer tout simplement
parce qu'on ne pourra pas les récupérer
bien non donc je souhaite connaître la
position du gouvernement à l'égard de
cette proposition de la Commission
européenne et de manière plus générale
quelles sont les propositions qui soient
faites pour accompagner la filière pêche
dans les difficultés aujourd'hui
pour vous répondre la parole éco
secrétaire d'été en charge de la mer
Monsieur Hervé Berville monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Michel canvettent
d'abord je vous remercie de votre
mobilisation dans un magnifique
territoire qui est le Finistère pour le
maintien et le développement de la
filière pêche française vous l'avez dit
cette proposition de la Commission
européenne d'interdire tout engin de
fond dans les aires marines protégées a
été évoqué il a quelques semaines à
Bruxelles je le dis très clairement ça a
été rappelé par la première ministre au
salon de l'agriculture par le Président
de la République au salon de
l'agriculture et par moi-même il y a de
cela deux semaines au calvados la France
le gouvernement est totalement opposé à
cette communication et à la mise en
oeuvre de l'interdiction des engins de
fond dans les aires marines protégées
totalement clairement et fermement pour
moi trois raisons la première c'est que
ça ne reconnaît absolument pas et sa
méconnait même les efforts fait depuis
des années par les pêcheurs et donc nous
voyons vous l'avez évoqué je le connais
bien et je sais l'attachement notamment
aussi du sénateur Alain cadet sur ce
sujet que les pêcheurs avec les efforts
qu'ils ont fournis depuis des années ont
permis la reconstitution de nombreux
stocks dont les stocks de coquilles
Saint-Jacques deuxièmement c'est une
prime au mauvais élève parce que tous
les pays qui du coup ont mis des aires
marines protégées se retrouvent
désormais sanctionnés et obligé et bien
d'interdire ces engins de fond et puis
c'est une folie pour la souveraineté
alimentaire de notre pays nous dépendons
déjà à plus de 80% un très bon texte du
sénateur Cadec avait évoqué ce sujet là
nous dépendons à 80% des importations
pour les produits de la pêche et nous
allons donc continuer à augmenter cette
part d'importation donc nous disons très
clairement il faut arrêter de poser le
développement de la filière halieutique
avec la question la protection la
biodiversité de la marine nous pouvons
m'emmener les deux de front et nous
l'avons démontré en France depuis des
années et la priorité du gouvernement
elle est de faire en sorte qu'on
continue à avoir des capacités de
production d'entraîner toute la filière
sur la décarbonation et la réduction aux
énergies fossiles et nous l'avons
démontré puisque nous soutenons cette
filière avec par quatre fois la
prolongation des aides carburants et
également par le soutien partout sur nos
territoires à cette belle filière
monsieur canoë merci monsieur le
ministre de cet engagement fort du
gouvernement les marins-pêcheurs
l'attendent et effectivement il convient
d'être particulièrement actif parce que
demain c'est une question de
souveraineté et effectivement le je sais
que le sénateur alakadec mais c'est
plutôt un pêcheur dormmo et aussi
attaché à tout cela en tout cas nous
sommes nous mobilisés et merci de votre
engagement merci nous allons terminer
merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres les
prochaines questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement ont lieu le mercredi 15
mars à 15h je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour la suite
de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale la séance est suspendue